hey what's up everyone its micromotor
closed and I wish shooting this quick
video to show you how easy market
analysis is now with the new order
closed trader 2.0 for ninja trader 8 now
before I begin brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell a futures contract or making any
other type of investment decision
futures train contains substantial risk
and is not for every investor investor
could potentially lose all their more
than the initial investment risk capital
is my I could be lost without
jeopardizing one's financial security or
lifestyle only risk CalPERS should be
used for trading annoying those with
sufficient risk capital should consider
trading pasture corns is not necessarily
indicative of future results so that
said I'm gonna do is I'm gonna show you
a few days of a few markets I'll show
you like crude oil since a lot of people
are interested in crude show you your
currency and if I got time I'll jump
into the e-mini s so this is crude oil
again I this is you see this is May 16th
right here the date down in here and I'm
just going to take you through a few
days showing you some of the new
features of order flows trader that runs
on ninja trader 8 this is the new
version that we're just releasing if
you're on the previous version I'll be
sending out an email with a link that
you can download it so one of the new
features is we highlight these areas of
point controls that I think are
important based on the order flow this
is my own order flow analysis tool and
what it does if it's if I think there's
resistance it'll draw a draw on the
point control as magenta color if I
think it's supportive it'll draw cyan
color as you'll see so again May 16th
this is the middle of the night here we
got divergence with ratio afterwards
which is a nice order flow setup I like
you also got the prominent point of
control market cells off cells off cells
off get down here you've got divergence
but just the divergence by itself I
usually like to see something else
coming in here you got a sign up trap
traders people getting short in the hole
and you see how the market makes a nice
move up similar thing up here here you
have a divergence and here you have a
prominent point of control so I know
there's resistance selling coming in
here I've got also it's also a
divergence can't see it it's hidden
behind this red arrow and there's also a
sign of trapped trader so you know up
here at this high area it's indicating
to me that you know the market is
getting primed for a sell-off
I would love to
a bearish ratio up in here it's not
there but I've seen other things I've
seen trap traders I'm seeing prominent
opponent control seeing single prints
and you see how the market sells off
down in here here also you got trap
traders down here at the low you know
one of the futures people I said hey
what's this red box around the bar some
of these bars have them some don't it
tells you if there's multiple imbalances
in the bar that's one of the features of
anti 8 that we've added you know you
have a stacking balance which you have
here which is imbalances stacked on top
of each other but if you have a if you
have the pink box around it it'll tell
you that you have multiple imbalances
you know like here you have one then you
got two down here you know here you've
got one of them to up here they're not
stacked imbalances in the sense that you
have threes literally stacked right on
top of each other but you know what it's
just as important to me but again you
know take it in context of the market
you know we've already been making the
move down and you're getting the selling
imbalances which I'm moving down you
should be selling imbalances what I'd be
looking for is you know right after
swing lows if there's that you know
multiple imbalances coming in you know
that's also a bullish sign but you know
here was the signal that we got you know
trap traders down here not here you got
a prominent point of control they'll
follow it up with multiple imbalances
market turned around though it just came
right down you got a little short-lived
move up then in here is nothing really
special going on it's just your normal
order flow get down in here you got a
prominent point of control this is right
before the API number again you here you
got you know some trap traders but again
you're not gonna probably take a trade
in a one way or the other I wouldn't in
front of the API numbers and as you can
see how the market reacted after the API
but you know what you were getting the
bullish signals you know for what it's
worth again you know I think it takes a
strong trader to do that because you
know you're not trying to predict the
API you just reading what's happening in
the order flow and when the API comes
out one way or the other market can
react quite violently
so you see 9:30 in here it's still wait
for it to calm down here and you got
this problem in point of control here
after about a minute market sells off to
an area we got a prominent point of
control market rallies back up you got
some divergences here but you're seeing
you know if you haven't sold off yet
right most people think that hey I got a
divergence I get short but you know
should really be looking for some sign
in the order flow here you've got prime
opponent control prominent point of
control coming in here so you know I
know there's resistance selling market
starts to come off I mean you do have a
bullish ratio here but nothing in you
know no other form of support like in
the bar market keeps going down just
sort of confirming that move down you've
got you know I got a bearish ratio you
got multiple imbalances or multiple
imbalances as you know it wouldn't just
what you would be expecting to see when
the markets selling off here you got a
support of buying coming in kind of
short lived came right down hit a new
low then more supportive buying coming
in as you took out that this swing low
here market got the bounce up you got
the confirming signal here with the
sweep but with the zero print and you
get up here you got trapped traders at
the swing high market reacts it sells
off to an area where you got some
support of mine and the point of
controls probably point of control here
just sort of goes sideways making a
little new higher a higher high here
primary point of control doesn't really
work out just sort of go sideways pop up
through there start coming off here you
got a problem important control but it's
a met immediately with the the we call
it the zero print indicator here trap
traders on the way down multiple
imbalances so you know you know just
because if you were to buy this bar here
because of the the supported buying you
still got to read what's happening in
the order flow immediately afterwards
right you got got the zero print you got
multiple imbalances yet all negative
Delta so even if you're still long you
should be out and in short market sells
off you get down here at a bullish ratio
rallies up to a bearish ratio kind of
goes sideways time is it's twelve
o'clock here got a bullish point of
control here to sort of go sideways
sideways a little bit starts working its
way up here you've got the sweep the
zero prints coming in now you're running
about 1:30 in the afternoon things are
sort of quieting down you know you've
got two bearish ratios followed by two
bullish ratios same with the point of
controls market does shoot up then
you're in the evening session here
already this is seven just after seven
o'clock you've got trap traders you've
got a prominent point of control
it sells off a little bit doesn't take
out the previous point of control at
this point you know so what is that 71
91 about to sort of come up right around
that same area again prominent point of
control so I know at that area around
the 71 91 92 area I've got selling here
I got some trapped Raiders as well up
there market sells off from the the 90
area down into the 70s starts turning
around coming back up finally takes it
out as we take out that prominent point
of control you see the aggressive buying
coming in in the imbalances which is
always a good sign it's some data come
out there and you're up then we run it
in here we got a trap trader Mike it
sells off a little bit here you got
divergence with the parameter point
control doesn't really sell off then you
get up here to this new high
you've got single print you got a
bearish ratio you've got a very strong
prominent point of control so you got
several things going for you okay so you
know even though you lost on this trade
right here if you just were to trade the
naked prominent point of control by
itself again I don't always advocate
that you know look for some more signs
in the order flow and you get this nice
move down from you know the 20 70 to 30
area down to the 7200 it starts working
its way back up you've got a problem a
point of control right on the top you
got the bearish ratio and you know boom
what happens again from the 7225 area
back down to below seventy one seventy
two hundred and another prominent point
of control just goes sideways that time
here you got some very strong trapped
traders it followed up by multiple
selling imbalances now people say well
you know you have multiple buying
imbalances here short the market go
higher well yeah it can but it did at
the same time you also have to read
what's happening in the order flow I
mean just because you got multiple
imbalances here multiple imbalances here
you know when you get to this bar what
do you got yeah very strong trapped
traders in here then you got multiple
selling imbalances so you shouldn't be
thinking well I have the stack buying a
balance I should still be long no you
should think about getting out once you
see this bar and when you see that bar
as well come down in here some support
of mine and the point of controls here
you got a ratio you've got the prominent
point of control sell off go sideways I
got some selling pressure coming in here
mark is just going sideways sideways
finally pops back up get to the swing
high pilot point of control bearish
ratio immediately afterwards start
working away down down down here you got
divergence with no ratio it's just the
divergence yeah
you know personally I prefer to get
something else than just a naked
divergence like that market rallies up
here you've got multiple imbalances but
you know I'd like to see multiple
imbalances closer to a low rather than
after the end of a move you get up here
you also got some trapped Raiders down
in here people trapped Raiders day at
this point I'm looking at support of
mine then we get up here we got trapped
Raiders he also you know trapped Raiders
as well it's a sweep and then boom the
market goes down so again don't get
fixated on this you have to keep reading
what's happening in the market you know
when conditions change it can change
immediately immediately in the next bar
in the next 10 seconds the next 30
seconds you know you gotta be able to
react in and read it don't just think
well you know what I've got to be long
because of this bar right here know when
the next part comes in and is bearish
and the bar afterwards comes in is
bearish think about getting short okay
you got a couple of divergences here
again just making divergences the market
pops up pops up to the naked point
control comes down in here you got
trapped Raiders you got a prominent
point of control here market makes it a
nice move higher yeah it's going higher
runs into this problem in point control
but then you know you got bullish ratio
you've got you know potential sweep here
and market keeps moving up here you got
trapped Raiders here you've got trapped
Raiders then you're running into the
close this is the reopen at five o'clock
this is like what day is this this is
going into Friday morning already you
know this is that silly time during Asia
during the reopen where it's just sort
of quiet then we come in here we got a
divergence so the prominent point of
control nothing happens
Nixon's new high here got positive Delta
though but again you got a prominent
point of control look how well this
market trades right back up to that
prominent point of control it holds and
then you got another prominent point of
control what happens boom it's lights
out market sells off from the 71-75 area
down into the below 70 150 keeps going
lower here you got divergence nothing
telling you to buy that by itself that's
just the naked divergence and even here
you got a potential you know more
selling pressure coming in
with that red arrow telling you there's
there's some strong sellers basically
wiping out the bids get this divergence
no ratio no primary point control
nothing is just a regular divergence
again you know I'm not a big fan of just
buying divergences by themselves I like
to pair them up with imbalances with
primary point controls with ratios you
started getting the ratio in here it's a
little bit far removed but you got the
multiple imbalances or rally up here we
got a ratio and a primary point of
control and we sawed off quite nicely
now we're at 9:00 in the morning on
believe it's Friday here probably
appoint control which is sort of goes
sideways it bounces from there to there
then you get here assigned to trap
traders you get the arrow indicating
potential move lower it runs into this
area here with the support of buying but
then again it comes right back with the
bearish ratio and you make the new low
here you have your divergence with the
ratio and a prominent point of control
excuse me so you know these are the
types of trades that I like to get you
know not just the divergence by itself
like like you had back here divergence
divergence because you know what the
market can still keep going lower I like
to pair it up with you know other signs
in the order phone and I'm getting it
you know I've got my bullish ratio ratio
pounds low indicating supported buying
and I've got the prominent point of
control as well which is nice and you
know again your rally up from 70 134 you
come up here to you know 70 150 where
you got the bearish ratio again and you
just sort of bounce around sideways in
here so you know that's a nice little
move to get then you come up here you
got a prominent point of control runs
into this next problem opponent control
on the buy side and then you run back up
in here you get the trap traders just on
the other side of that prominent point
of control what happens boom sells off
quite nicely gets one prominent point of
control here then you get you know the
obviously the big seller coming in but
you again get the sine of some trap
traders in here market doesn't really
muster much of a move up you got
multiple imbalances in this bar you've
got you know the bearish ratio so you
know even if you were long here this is
a sign to be getting out of that market
you run into some more trap traders down
here again markets moving pretty fast at
this point it's kind of a fast market
condition bearish ratio
comes down here you know starts working
its way back up
you know honestly this this this area in
here but that 11:07 time you again you
know 11:07 is here too to here there's
moving pretty fast it was something that
came out at that time market starts
moving back up I'm a point of control
that doesn't work then you get some
trapped Raiders here there you have them
here then you know these these guys that
were long and wrong you know started
covering their shorts you know this
happens to a lot of people you know they
they think well I'm buying it here for
the breakout and they buy it here then
they start taking some heat then they
capitulate get out and also now they
they found themselves long and wrong now
they're short in the hole you know maybe
they reversed and it's indicating that
in the order flow and you can see how
the market makes this nice move up and
here you get this new prominent point of
control right up in here bearish ratio
bearish ratio market sells off a little
bit I mean here you have a bullish ratio
but again you know it's it's just on
this little dip here I'm not convinced
that it's the start of a big move again
I'm looking at a lot of bearish signs
here and it's coming in after just a big
move up another prominent point of
control but in here the single print
single print bearish ratio you know more
single prints as you're sort of going
into the close of the week so that was
crude oil that was crude oil for the
last few days of last week let's take a
look at euro currency really quick I
don't wanna keep this I don't wanna make
this video too long I'll I prefer to
keep it a bit bit shorter here that's
why I like to ninja trader 8 because you
can see how fast it refreshes so again
I'll just go back what day is this I
don't look at the calendar here so may
16th but it start from May 16th
cuz that's all this time here is just
the from the reopen but may 16th which
was Wednesday where are we here here's
May 16th so again primary point of
control comes off a little bit to some
trap traders here Mike it shoots up a
little bit it starts coming off again
you got the multiple imbalances here
with a little bit of a sweep again it's
happening and just before the European
open so markets are kind of thin got a
nice prominent point of control here for
resistance selling and just by looking
at that volume
again it's coming in right under the
previous resistance selling as well
market makes a nice little move down
some trap traders again as you sort of
come back up in there what I'd be
looking for now is either the move lower
at this time at 2:16 if it's not coming
I'd be looking for signs in the order
flow that maybe it's you know if I can't
get that sell off what's gonna happen
two things either gonna go sideways or
it's going to start rallying in this
case I see a sign in here with the sweep
and the market coming through multiple
imbalances and we start moving higher
here we got a divergence here we got a
prominent point of control the market
starts working its way down it's doing
it reluctantly grudgingly working its
way down but again there's still no
reason to be if you're short there's
still no reason to be getting out you
know there's no reason to be buying in
here even the deltas are kind of small
one-seven-one
and then boom you get a sweep in here
that's how you get a trap traders in
here you've got multiple imbalances we
sell-off you got a bullish ratio you got
the primary point control puts a
half-hearted rally up in here
stacked selling and balance here you got
a trap traders then you get a new
prominent point of control down here at
the swing low start rallying start
rallying again another prominent point
of control but doesn't happen the move
doesn't happen here we get a sweep
coming in the market here in the order
flow followed by a bearish prominent
point of control so you got a couple
bearish things happening in here so you
know even if you're long from you know
this area you know say you're long from
here on this bar or this bar you know by
the time you get out here your
conditions have changed you know
sometimes you know people like to get
married to a position and they're afraid
to cut it but you know what you got to
be reading what's happening in the
market and in here it's very bearish
signs in the order flow and then the
market puts a nice move down you know
that that's the movie looking for here
you had divergence with the prominent
point control again sort of a
half-hearted rally you got some
confirming signs and trap traders there
but that was it that didn't happen then
you got the bearish ratios coming in you
know you don't have the prominent Pony
controls but again you're bearish ratios
to be assigned to you that hey you know
maybe this move higher is not happening
here is resistance selling here is
priced
even got the single print market cells
off you get down here to a prominent
point of control bullish one followed up
with you know the ratio that you like
and multiple imbalances again next bar
up next bar up then it turns around and
starts coming back down single print
there then you start coming in here
getting into about 6:30 in the morning
multiple imbalances and a prominent
point of control followed up with
potential sweep in the market and what
happens is the market makes its move
down here you do have you know trap
traders but it's followed up again with
multiple selling imbalances with another
sweep in that market so you know if
you're short here your covers because of
this bar by the time this bar is done
again you should be short again because
yeah you know that's that's what
training is about is getting in and outs
based on what you're reading in the
market but you know everyone talks about
you gotta cut your losses short let your
winners run this is how you cut your
losses short by reading what's happening
in the market and reacting to it so you
know if you're short from here okay
you're covered maybe you got you know
whatever a few ticks out of it but now
you're now you're you're long but then
when this bar comes in and you read
what's happening in the order flow with
the sweep with the multiple imbalances
you should not be long anymore and you
should be getting short and you can
catch this move back down from you know
the once 18:08 below down to you know
down here we got a prominent point of
control indicating support you know so
that's from you know one 1808 to one
1798 that's 20 ticks in the in the your
currency again you know if you get long
here that's great you would have caught
the move back up I'm not saying you have
to constantly be doing that you know
honestly after you get your little win
here a little loss there then the nice
move you know I know a lot of traders
will just take a break you know a smoke
break or something or but you know again
you know it's giving you a signal
potential buy down here we rally up
rally up you know nothing major in the
order flow telling you it really there
gets short you got the ratio in the
single print then here you got a
prominent point of control then you
start coming down problem to put a
control for the cell you start coming
down you guys suite potential sweeps
there you get down here you got a ratio
and divergence stack that's stacked
buying balance rather multiple buying
imbalances again this is what I say you
know
time's the market I think just really
tells you is stuffy I mean for me this
is like the you know the quarterback
hands you the ball and you run to the
end zone you know you got to get long
then you come down in here you got signs
of price rejection right so you say
you're not convinced in here by this bar
you should be convinced and you know get
the nice move up you got you no signs of
trapped Raiders down here here you got
sweeps here you got support of mine
coming in you know those are the trains
that you look for on a daily basis that
that happen quite frequently your rally
all the way up in here you got you know
confirming multiple imbalances you get
up here you've got you know buried your
first bearish ratio so you got your main
potentially first sign for getting out
of the position you got single print
single print so imagine you know if you
were to buy this load where you have the
divergence you have the primary point of
control you have the multiple imbalances
you know you're getting along 117 you
know I'll call one 1796 right in here or
even here oh you know one 1798 all the
way up to order your first sign that
this move is potentially over is up here
one 1834 one 1832 is taking out one 1830
you know you're talking 6070 tix there
in the in the euro currency you gots to
sign the trap traders here with
prominent point of control doesn't work
out market sells off a little bit then
again you got the prominent point of
control here you got multiple in this
case you got stacked and balanced it
I'll draw the box whether it's stacked
or if it's separated like this one but
again you know that's what you're
looking for you're looking for signs in
the order flow not just one thing but if
you get two or three that's even better
then the market is just sort of hanging
around here going sideways you get
another prominent point of control
right before that big move up confirming
the move is you got the multiple
imbalances you get up here look at you
got you've got trap traders you got
multiple imbalances at the high here at
the swing high followed up with more
sweeping activity and the market moves
down I mean you do have multiple primary
point control there but again you know
if maybe you broke even on this trade
okay nothing major in here here's a
prominent point of control but then
again it comes in
you got trapped traders coming in
appearing here market starts selling off
selling off selling off here's probably
important control nothing really happens
a trap trader here now this is
interesting a couple bullish ratios down
here they all sort of at the swing low
but again nothing's really happening
here here you got a sign of potential
trap traders coming in and then the
market starts rallying you know this
this area honestly I felt was a little
bit tricky because you sort of got a
wade in and out of conflicting signals
but again you know you don't have to
catch every single move you'd like to
catch them all now this one here I
thought was interesting because here you
have a trap traders make this a little
bigger and you got multiple imbalances
at after a big move up okay and you get
short I would get short there ten out of
ten times and then it starts coming back
here I've got multiple imbalances a
prominent point of control
okay so pump sort at this point I'm
looking you know what this trades not
working out because I don't like to see
this bearish activity coming in or
bullish activity coming in here I expect
the market to start selling off and it's
not instead you have buyers coming in
got the red bar okay I'm not fazed by
that but then you got a sweep coming in
here and multiple imbalances and you
know the market makes another
short-lived moved up and it just sort of
goes sideways the higher we get no major
reason to sell you if I got short here
it's bomb followed up with some nice
bullish signals coming through in there
and this one here this was nice as it
around 1:30 in the afternoon one o'clock
rather prominent control followed up
with a bearish ratio you know the single
print as well you make this nice move
down into this area where you got some
trapped traders down here and you're
just going into that close already this
is you know 4 o'clock 5 o'clock 4
o'clock close and the five o'clock
reopen coming in here so I'm not too
convinced down on this stuff I would
have liked to get a bigger move faster
you know sometimes those moves from
after 2:00 p.m. to 4:00 p.m. are quite
slow but again you would have been
slightly rewarded for your patience this
is the the asian session again you're
seeing the same thing say over here you
got a couple divergences here you got a
sweep
multiple imbalances you got the problem
opponent control with the divergence and
again look how this market keeps going
up I mean these are the tools
this is my sort of thought process that
I've put into all the tools of the order
closed trader to help you sort of go
through the same thought process I mean
you know I'll say I used to run a
trading room for how many years and I
was just you know sit there and talk
about what I'm seeing in the order flow
and you know honestly I felt like it was
a bit redundant at times because I would
be talking about the same things over
and over and over I thought there's got
to be a way to put it into the software
and that's what I've done I've done to
highlight these areas to you so that you
can you know sort of see it yourself and
make the decision because if you just
look at a normal volume footprint chart
without these tools you're not gonna
know what you're looking at right you're
just gonna be looking okay there's
there's numbers here there's some
binding balances okay what do I do you
know here is telling you there's trapped
traders up here at the swing high you
come down in here some you know some
support of mind some resistance selling
you know honestly that was this was one
of the ways I traded you know I would
look for a supportive buying sell it up
here whether it is resistant selling
gets short again and just do that back
and forth all day long you know when I
was when I was scalping now I'd be
buying it based off this you know taken
however many ticks out of the market at
a time okay so here you're coming into
the European open it's kind of quiet you
got this last prominent porting control
this one doesn't really work out you're
staring at a lot of bearish signals in
between now you sort of got this clear
path you're not looking at bearish
signals though that you were looking at
just prior to them market makes a nice
move up multiple stack imbalances in
here rather again a sweep coming into
the market and look I mean it makes this
nice move from the 40s all the way up to
all the way up to 60
and then again you know this is stuff
that I think is you know if people don't
know what to look for that's why I like
to highlight it because you know people
don't know what to look for so here you
got the multiple selling imbalances here
you got signs of a sweep okay and you
see how the market reacts to that you
know that's why I created the software
is to make the order flow analysis
easier for people because you know I
could sit there and tell people okay you
look for this look for that look for
that on the order flow and you know some
people can do it some people can you
know if there was a way to put it make
it more visual for you I think that's
gonna make it a lot easier so that's why
you know we have these arrows that's why
we have these boxes so you can see this
stuff happening I'm here in case Oh
cells off again from the 52 area down to
you know the 30s you got some you got
some trapped Raiders here with this
arrow followed up by bearish signs more
trapped Raiders but it's coming in a
move already that you've already been
participating in you know prominent
point of control followed by another
problem point of control you get down
here you got divergence no ratio I'd
love to have a ratio or prominent point
of control and they'll really give me a
sign to catch that move okay I probably
wouldn't have taken it this is the Delta
surge happening right in here actually
if you're familiar with that indicator
on my website that reads the Delta but
that's the Delta search I can't tell you
that right now then you come up in here
you got a bearish ratio again yeah yeah
that's followed by a multiple imbalances
so you know you just had to move up and
get starting to see some bearish sign
you see the aggressive selling coming in
the market sells off alright you got a
problem to put in control here Mike
starts to rally fails then you got
another divergence again this one I
probably want to take either I probably
don't caught that move that was a nice
move to catch let's follow the pole
multiple multiple imbalances here on the
way up again you get down up here you
got a prominent point of control there's
only two in the morning you know there's
a lot of activity going on already
during the year some multiple imbalances
here then met with bearish sign with the
prominent point control bearish sign
their market sells off you know you got
you got sweep right here you can see how
the market reacts and you get this nice
problem opponent control here single
prints market works its way back down
you've got bullish problem point control
bullish one here multiple pointed
controls by multiple behind imbalances
you know at the bullish ratio you got
trap traders market makes a little bit
of a move higher I mean it doesn't look
like much but it's actually from one
1828 dollar if that one is that one 1832
decent move in New York really it's up
to 36 but you know you probably been
looking to covered around 32 and then
here you got a sweep you got multiple
imbalances again more imbalances in here
bearish ratio single print
market sells off again nicely again that
that's what if you're just looking for
stacking balances you're gonna miss this
right you'll see this this is stacked in
balance but you're not gonna see the
multiple and balance back here you know
it says coupled with a market sweep as
well so it's you know it's quite
powerful stuff problem opponent control
market or hell he's another prominent
point control market makes a little
half-assed rally sells off a little bit
here with this bearish point of control
multiple imbalances you're sort of at
this base area right you're sort of
rallied sold off going sideways boom
you've seen multiple by aggressive
traders coming in here on spread out
buying imbalances market makes a nice
move higher get up here some trap
traders at the swing high sells off a
little bit sells off to a prominent
point of control rallies back up nothing
in here really got a couple of selling
imbalances market leon and the sweep
mark doesn't really sell off maybe the
next this bar sells off a little bit but
you're sort of covers back then you run
back in here you get this prominent
point of control lines up sort of with
where you had the suspect imbalances
multiple imbalances rather sells off
again you got some trap traders and
sweep coming in there you got a here you
got stack the balance but then again
you've got prominent point of control
bearish one followed by a bullish one
followed by line imbalances multiple
binding balances followed by a sweep
happening in the market the market
continues rallying you got a problem to
put in control market just go sideways
though then you get down here primary
point control and a nice bullish ratio
followed up with a sign of trap traders
this is the bar you should have got long
on not this one you know with booth this
is a nice buying signal right there
doesn't make them massive move but look
where it comes back down to it comes
back down to this previous point of
control where you also have the ratio so
you know you got support of mine in here
comes right down in there again it makes
starts making that move back up and
you've seen bullish ratio you're seeing
you know sweeping activity in here
multiple buying imbalances in here
finally makes that move up starts coming
down what do you guys so you got the
swing high you got some selling
imbalances and there
a prominent point of control with
stacked imbalances market moves a little
bit higher and some trap traders in here
about which follows this bar with a
bearish ratio and multiple imbalances
okay you know it comes down to what your
time frame is you know some people be
happy to get five six ticks out of your
currency it portrayed some want to get
10 20 ticks you know there's different
ways to approach the market so he
started coming up in here you got some
signs of trap traders in here
obviously you see the market sell-off
quite nice it off of that you got the
bearish point of controlling here so
yeah we sell-off bounce up a little bit
there's still selling pressure okay and
my continues down here again this is I'm
talking about you know I just showed you
before this is now in the evening time
you've got a divergence you got a
bullish ratio you got a prominent point
of control you got multiple imbalances
you know I mean market is screaming at
you hey Mike buy me oh you know what
happens it's the market rallies you know
it goes from one 18 17 I like the one
1830s you get another divergence here
another prominent part of control this
time to sell and it's a multiple
imbalances so you know if you're a long
from here you could have taken a nice
ride up to you know one eighteen
seventeen all the way up to 118 no 29 28
and in this bars if I were to be getting
out looking to get short sort of hangs
around here primary point control sort
of line up it doesn't really sell off
you know you're sort of going into that
midnight time where it's kind of quiet
Philly European open special rallying
here this is a this is as the trade I
would have gotten short on didn't work
out pause by you know you got your
bearish ratio price rejection you got
your single print you're a prominent
point control comes right back with
buying and balances then you get up here
another prominent point of control
bearish ratio you know single print so
you got you got a few things you know
different things in the order flow
happening it's all bearish signs there's
no really bullish sign here you got
trapped traders here you got trapped
traders but again it's just you know
sometimes now the market just doesn't
cooperate it just goes sideways on you
you're looking at a few bullish or
bearish signs here followed by a few
bullish signs you get down here so are
the last man standing is this this
bullish sign you and you got the bullish
sign here with the trap traders here you
see single print single print single
print well you know so it's telling you
every time you start coming down you
know it's fewer sellers you know sellers
aren't really interested they're sort of
dwindling in that sense might get
rallies up you get a bearish ratio with
a single print and just sort of go
sideways with time is it's 3:00 in the
morning right now you can see here
nothing major again it's sometimes order
flow is a little bit confusing in the
sense that you get a bullish ratio
followed by you know a bullish sign
followed by a bearish sign again bullish
sign followed by a bearish sign but
again you know if you can line them up
with a few things it's always good it's
always better that way here you're
seeing a potential sweep then you're
seeing you know potential trap traders
finally coming in now you're getting the
move you know here you're getting short
it didn't happen you're getting stopped
out okay save your bullets right take
your loss look for the next potential
trade you know here you have prominent
point control it's sandwiched in between
these two bars which are very bearish
what are you gonna take okay so you're
not convinced by this bar with this
multiple imbalances in here you should
be convinced that the markets coming
down you know if you're getting short
here 118 26 look at that you catch a
nice move down you know maybe you
covered a little bit here you know 118
20 but then it comes right back you know
the bearish trade show and start selling
off quite nicely got down here to this
low here you got some trap traders
coming in here you can see them people
that you know sort of missed this move
thinking hey guys sell it start rallying
up oh it's a great opportunity for me to
get short again and they don't they're
stuck there shorting the whole market
rallies back up through this prominent
point control here sells off a little
bit to this next point of control then
you got this bar here high you know sort
of like this little mini double top but
you got multiple imbalances appearing in
here you got a single print market to
sort of go sideways unfortunately it
goes lower but you know to me it's
considered that sideways okay kids tell
me it's time to eat
actually this videos last going a bit
longer than I imagined but anyway I'll
just finish it up here this I think this
is a last name your currency so you got
a divergence here just a naked divergent
or divergence with the prominent point
of control right there
followed by you know some potential
traders shorten trying to get short in
the whole market rallies you know that's
what you're looking for
you know you're looking for these signs
in the order flow especially when
several things confirm you know market
direction here you've got trapped
traders here you got a prominent point
of control followed by you know multiple
imbalances followed by more multiple
imbalances and the words the market it
sells off quite nicely comes down to
where area we have supportive buying
coming in area where you got resistance
selling coming in more stacked selling
more selling imbalances again you got a
racial divergence this one failed well
look when it comes right back with it
comes right back with multiple and
balances so even if you get in long off
this I would get long off this and but
if I'm looking in the next bar and I got
a very bearish sign I'd be getting out
I'd be getting out no reason to hold
that and here you get down here primary
point control
you've got trap traders again it makes
sort of a half-lived move and there's
sort of go sideways doing this makes a
new low by a few ticks but again you got
that prominent point of control coming
in here you see the cyan color rallies
back up boom you get another bearish
sign in here with the point of control
market sells off I mean this is why you
know this is what I'm going through in
my thought process you can see that's
why you know I'm a visual person right I
love Instagram and stuff like that
because you seen pictures of everything
you see how it rallies from this point
of control to that point of control to
this point of control back up to this
and you know this as it's happening it
colors it in when I think it's important
you know I've written it out so you know
it can be coded so it'll show up right
as it's happening on these areas that
are important so imagine you're buying
it here hold anything there you get
short here then you guys buy signal here
you get long here you're getting out
here you know it's like you know here
there there you know that's what you
like again another one you're getting
short here you know this one is nice you
got a ratio yeah at the problem
important control you got multiple
imbalances you make a nice move up you
know anytime you could add you know a
few of these together confluence I think
it's the word that traders like to use I
it's it just makes trading a lot easier
you know here you got trapped traders
here you got trapped trader
with the multiple imbalances it fails
honestly it fails but you come down here
to support a buying okay
then again you got similar opposite of
this previous one you got the trap
traders you have the bearish ratio here
you don't have a ratio in the up
multiple imbalance it just runs into
this support of mind that you saw
earlier finally it sort of broke down
made that little new low and it's just
going sideways you know what can you do
you know this is you know they're
supportive buying in there anytime you
even get short going into an area of
support you know you got a lot to get
through and you get through it doesn't
necessarily mean it's going to keep
going going down then here you get some
trapped traders down in you know in this
move you can see it in the middle there
112 48 71 3-1 and boom market starts
moving back up and you go into well
that's it that's all the data that I had
for that week but anyway this is this
video is went on a bit longer I do want
to I want to try and create another one
later with kind of show minis a lot of
people are interested in minis this one
was on euro currency and crude oil but
again so you know this is the new
version of order closed trader and I
think it can help a lot of people make
their order flow trading a lot easier
okay so if you interested in the
software again you go to my website
order flows calm and be sure to
subscribe to my youtube channel because
any time I post videos up there at least
still be alerted to it if your
subscriber to my channel so thank you
and have a great day bye bye